bonjour bonjour à vous bonjour nicolas
alors où êtes-vous retrouvé ce matin sur
rtl france on lisait un nouveau
mouvement des gilets jaunes qui sont
venus sur les ronds points le week-end
dernier qu'est ce qu'on peut retenir de
cette mobilisation ah ben on va en
retirer victimes en les jeux les jeunes
ont fait leur retour samedi dernier sur
de nombreux ronds points partout en
france pour protester contre up contre
le prix exorbitant des carburants c'est
cette même étincelle rappelez-vous qui
avait mis le feu aux poudres populaire
en novembre 2018 pour ouvrir ce
mouvement historique longue de plusieurs
mois alors le premier il avait été réglé
avec beaucoup de lacrymogènes deux tiers
du lb des deux blessés graves de garde à
vue et de comparution immédiate mais
revoilà loger les jeunes et bizarrement
les médias main stream n'ont presque pas
évoquer cet appel national en amont
pourtant le hashtag gilet jaune saison 2
avait occupé les tendances de twitter
france pendant quelques heures en fin de
semaine dernière mais peut-être que
certains médias parisiens n'avaient pas
eu l'information à temps et si c'est le
cas il faudrait quand même penser à
changer les vieux minitel poussiéreux
les antennes réseau fixe et sur le toit
ou alors c'est simplement la bonne
vieille méthode coué de si on n'en parle
pas il n'existe pas mais par contre dès
dimanche matin certains médias
totalement muet à ce sujet était déjà
sur le coup peut venir que la
mobilisation des jeunes et jeunes
avaient été très timides samedi pour cet
appel national même les titres santé la
jubilation de celui qui sans vous dire
est bien fait et tac encore loupé celle
là qui l'a pas volé néanmoins il semble
que le contentement bobo médiatique aux
écolos mondiale au parisien soit un peu
hâtif et je vais prendre des exemples
qui devrait faire réfléchir le
gouvernement par exemple à montpellier
la manifestation contre le passé ni
terre a rejoint pour la première fois
samedi léger des jeunes sur le rond
point du quartier près d'arènes dans le
sud de la ville
ajoutez à cela l'exemple supplice pacs
actuellement à trieste en italie depuis
plusieurs jours ainsi que dans d'autres
villes royalement occultée par nos chers
médias main stream qui pourrait donner
des idées ici en france à certains alors
vous laissez donc entendre nicolas que
ces deux mouvements pourraient converger
ben oui on peut on peut l'estimer et
bien au vu de la situation de plus en
plus apocalyptique que traverse la
france du gouvernement du sous
secrétaire de préfecture le
charismatique jean castex mais plus
d'enthousiasmé à hacher menu les droits
au chômage à raboter les retraites et à
faire payer les pays r et les
antigénique qu'à prendre en compte le
courroux populaire qui ne cesse de
grandir chaque jour un peu plus c'est en
réalité cher ami le grand scheelen des
mauvaises idées dans lesquels dans
laquelle il faut s'armer d'incompétence
et de langue de bois car la langue de
bois elle sert justement à masquer
l'incompétence et surtout le néant alors
pourquoi magali une convergence d'un
côté les mesures sanitaires qui devait
s'arrêter dans la seconde où la
situation s'améliorait devrait se
poursuivre jusqu'à l'été 2022 ça aucun
contrôle parlementaire avouez que cela
ça fait une très très très longues
secondes et maintenant on réfléchit
gouvernement à ce que le pass annie
terre puisse inclure une troisième dose
de vaccin donc les 12 vacciner repartir
et à la case départ sans passer encore
par la case prison cela pourrait être
suffisamment énarque pour énerver
quelques centaines de milliers de
vacciner qui pourrait avoir un sens de
l'humour de plus en plus approximatif
avec des fulgurances sanitaire d'olivier
la science du moins on l'espère sans
compter que payer pour les tests
commencent à ressembler de plus en plus
à des amendes déguisée de l'autre côté
vous avez la tribu des pieds nickelés
avec bruno le maire barbara conflit et
jean castex qui tente de trouver un truc
pour faire baisser les tarifs des
carburants sans baisser les taxes de
l'état là on touche au ridicule mais au
gouvernement il appelle cela des
arbitrages c'est comme une sorte de
consignes d'actionnaires où tout le
monde tout le monde finalement garde ses
mains dans ses poches en refusant de
remettre anglais de 20 alors que dehors
des milliers de français font tous les
jours des équations à quadriple inconnu
où il faut choisir entre aller bosser
aller faire ses courses ou aller
promener ses gamins et nicolas est ce
que la possible conjonction de ces
contestations pourrait prendre de
l'ampleur dans les jours à venir et bien
ce matin il s'agit de se poser les
bonnes questions aux charges et demi
alors que reste-t-il aux français alors
que sur leur carte d'identité il n'ya
plus inscrire et plus française mais
république de l'état d'urgence orné d'un
fuyard code que reste-t-il aux français
lorsque l'assemblée nationale où il n'y
a que 170 députés présents sur un texte
aussi important pour l'article 1 que
reste-t-il aux français lorsque 380
députés ne daigne pas assisté à la chute
de notre démocratie eh bien ils auraient
emmanuel bardon qui veut pourfendre les
maisons individuelles lotissement depuis
son pavillon cossu de la banlieue
parisienne car cette vitesse est un non
sens écologique il ne reste aussi manuel
macron qui fait du foot contre des
soignants qui tire des penaltys et qui
est à un orteil de ce trouble proclamé
ballon d'or sous le regard bienveillant
de brigitte macron qui est venu lui
apporter des belles et les compotes et
on ne parlera même pas de retracer
mi-temps sans gestes barrières hormis
pour le petit personnel en réalité
depuis les gilet jaune il ne reste plus
grand chose aux français épris de
liberté pour se faire entendre ils pour
contester dans les nuages de gaz
lacrymogènes
en réalité des millions de français sont
pris en otage sous le poids d'un pouvoir
de plus en plus liberticides et en
réalité des millions de français n'ont
aujourd'hui plus aucune confiance dans
leur assemblée nationale à cause des
députés qu'ils ont élu et qui ne sont
pas à l'assemblée aujourd'hui les miens
de fond c'est son seul face à la
politique brutale des manuels m'apprend
qui a réussi son pari divisés comme
jamais et il faut relire toujours en
arène qui écrivait je cite les
mouvements totalitaires sont des
organisations main cible d'individus
atomisés est isolé il faut lire le
dernier livre de françois hollande aux
siens si on veut en apprendre plus sur
exactement et celui de gérard davet et
fabrice lhomme le trône est en très bon
bouquin merci beaucoup nicolas c'était
l'édito politique ne la matinale